what up guys welcome to the judge pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to my
whiteboard videos today I am going to go
over the hierarchy
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and ring that
notification it's all the way you're
gonna be notified of my daily videos so
this last week I decided that I wanted
to know more about
nice ladies and wifey material
oh I forgot to add one sorry guys hold
on
okay ladies and wifey material so this
week we did a show where we really
wanted to define the terms because a lot
of men out there cannot Define what's a
what's a lot of the women it's
like what is this and I'd like to tell
you guys in 2023 you go by a historical
point of view 95 of women would be
however we are in 2023 so we got to
adapt to the time so I surveyed some men
to see what they think the definition
that we came up with was
someone that has sex for money or does
things for money
is someone who does it for sex
someone that does it for attention so we
went through some scenarios as a class
Okay so
is it only fans worker a stripper or an
escort I guess well that's cool never
mind that now a is a woman who
cheats on her boyfriend one cheats on
her boyfriend one night stands because
what's she doing it for next we have a
hoe now this is a girl ass pics on the
gram okay or 15 plus bodies now okay
guys there's been a lot of dispute some
guys are saying no it's way less than
that look it I I just asked the people I
just I just report the news let me know
if there's anything else we should add
to the top three but that's what we got
for now so a nice lady we concluded can
have so then we have a lady so a lady
have roughly 5 to 14 teen bodies okay
but she cannot have gotten these through
one night stands so no one night stands
can only have gotten the bodies so maybe
you've got ghosted took anal but you
could still be a lady if you have five
to fourteen bodies now let's define a
nicely zero to five bodies is a nice
lady and wifey is a virgin is wife
material so now that we have some
definitions what I wanted to do was I
wanted to make a hierarchy of how back
to you what the market don't shoot the
messenger okay ladies all right so here
we have the least desirable here we have
the most desirable and most rare So what
is going to go on the least desirable
level in terms of sluttiness this is the
hierarchy of all right so at the bottom
we have
pokers now there's many names for these
ladies
um escort escorts um Street Walkers
night walkers but at the end of the day
they're selling for money okay above
we have
stars now because they're not just
straight selling sex they have less
partners are above hookers next only
fans ladies you're not at the bottom but
you're not far from it you're just about
stars then only fans next we have
strippers now A Stripper can go on to
live a normal life because there's no
maybe you didn't sell sex for money I
mean we all know what goes on in the
strip clubs but maybe she just stripped
so then now this is the most disputed
one I asked the men what's worse would
you rather take a single mother or a
woman with a high body count now we all
know that they're single mothers with
high body count like we all know but I I
said you have to pick one and the men
picked drum roll please
high body count if you sleep with too
many people you are barely better than a
strip now what number this is is very
disputed across the board
um I I've heard numbers like around 25
it switches they'd rather take a single
mom I've had some guys say 10. I've had
some guys say 30. I don't know when it
switches exactly for men but let's just
say somewhere between 15 to 30 they'll
take the kid over the body don't shoot
the messenger now remember if you have
bowl Five if you just have a kid and not
the body count lightly above but not by
much I mean
and remember bubble of ladies our mid
body counts so again I've had some
dispute but what I've gotten is like
five to like 15 roughly men will take
that over the kid but it switches around
there then we have low body count which
nowadays is like under 10 under five
again please don't shoot the messenger
I'm just repeating back what I've been
told and at the top
virgins so this is the hierarchy of
boredom from Lee to most
let me let me if there's anything I
forgot guys you know I love giving these
lessons to you
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notifications Bell
and I will talk to you guys next time